if you're a real estate professional and
with all the mess that's going on in
America today interest rates Powell
three quarts of a basis point valuation
drop in inventory going up oh my God
what's going to happen in real estate
but Pat I am not leaving the industry
like to see from Wolf of Wall Street I'm
not leaving they can't make me leave
that's you today's video is for you
okay so Point number one during this
season the bottom 80 is going to get
destroyed the top 20 is going to be okay
the top one percent won't even feel it
so what can you do to be in the top one
percent of your industry I'm at a comedy
show with Maz jabroni it's Father's Day
my my wife my family invites me we go
there Mazda speaking is doing his part
that's the second time I'm watching my
brought them back to us six years ago
and he gets up and he says he's talking
to his agent during covet there's
nothing going on he's in La everything's
been shut down right there is no work
there is no comedy shows there's no
touring they're not doing movies how do
I make money his agent says Mars
I don't care what you do every day
create one piece of content and all you
do whether you're getting paid or not
create one piece of but I'm not getting
paid it doesn't matter create a piece of
content every day so what does Moz do he
says all right whatever I listen to my
agent my manager he starts creating a
piece of content next thing you know
boom one goes viral boom Another one
goes viral boom Another one goes viral
and people are calling him hey can you
do this hey can you do that can you do a
zoom comedy can you do that and then now
afterwards because of all the videos and
all the eyeballs that he got people are
saying oh my God that's Moz I saw him
clip on this I saw this I saw that I saw
that he increases market value so when
covet was done boom the demand went up
same as you today for you is a great
opportunity to create unique content
talking about current times and the way
I would do this in a following way think
about how currently customers feel about
real estate make those fears make those
anxieties make those concerns that they
have and create a video speaking to them
then create videos with realtors that
are concerned fears that they have
concerns that they have and talk to them
and not in a fake way of saying it's you
know realistic don't believe the BS
don't believe this don't believe that no
some of it is real we gotta have a real
conversation together the more sincere
the more real you're going to be at a
time like this when there's nothing else
to do then create content you're going
to get eyeballs so when the market comes
back up everyone's going to say that
real estate professional I saw him so
many times on Facebook Instagram Twitter
YouTube I want to talk to that guy
today's sponsors Masterworks matter of
fact I really like what Masterworks does
because a lot of people can't afford to
buy a whole art piece for two million
dollars what Masterworks does is they
buy the art piece they file it with the
SEC then members are able to buy and
sell shares that's what they do now keep
in mind you know this is like you can't
buy all of Apple for two and a half
trillion dollars but you can buy an
Apple stock for a few hundred dollars
similar story one thing you need to know
about how much wealth is being held in
art today is an estimated 1.7 trillion
dollars millionaires billionaires have
help their wealth and art Deloitte says
it's going to increase another 900
billion dollars by 2026 what Masterworks
does is the last five paintings they saw
since 2017 their average rate of return
was 26.8 percent and Contemporary Art
prices have outperformed S P 500 Total
return ready by 164 percent the past 26
years so if this is something you want
to take advantage of we're going to put
the link below there is a waiting list
for people that are trying to get into
this program with Masterworks but
because you're part of valuetainment if
you click on the link below and you go
through the item you will skip the
waiting list and you'll be able to start
buying and selling shares immediately
Point number two don't let fear
immobilize you when I was working on
Morgan Stanley Dean with it was my first
day was 9 10 a day before 9 11. when 9
11 hit we're at the office Dave Kirby
sends everybody home we come back the
next day 912 and the look on everyone's
face was unbelievable our headquarters
goes on our World Trade Center 3600
employees and Dave says guys whatever
you do pick up the phones don't be
afraid of the phones the guy in the
corner office making 700k a year was
afraid to pick up the phones because
everybody was calling them so every day
that went by that he didn't pick up the
phone and contact his customers somebody
else did and they left them during a
time like this a lot of times Realtors
are afraid to call their existing people
that they sold or existing customers
this happens in every industry by the
way stock Brokers doesn't matter who you
are this applies to every industry you
do the opposite and pick up the phone
and get right into it hey John hey Mary
how are you look in the industry one of
the biggest challenges most Realtors are
not calling their clients I'm calling
you right now to ask you how you feeling
how are things how you think about
what's going on with the economy right
now do you have any questions for me and
you process it with them that customer
is going to get off the phone saying wow
what a courageous guy what a tough guy
because if there's one reputation many
Realtors have if they were men they're
known for being one one night stand
professionals they sell a house and they
never call the customer back because
they got their commissions we've all
experienced this before
this is the wrong time to treat your
customers that way it's always a wrong
time to treat them that way but this is
definitely the wrong time to treat them
that way pick up the phone call them
Point number three when covet happened
everybody was afraid we had no clue what
was going to happen all the insurance
companies were like oh my God the first
thing clients are going to cancel is
their insurance policies what are we
going to do we got to get a hold of
these guys we got to get out how are we
going to handle this stuff I went to the
home office I had a meeting I said guys
here's what we're doing what are we
doing we are sending five dollar gift
cards to our customers what do you mean
we're sending five dollar gift card
Amazon cards to our customers Pat that's
a big cost I totally get it but we're
going to send a five dollar gift card
to our customers Pat that's in the tens
of that I understand but we're gonna
send these five dollar gift cards to
them and just say the following line you
ready what is it I just wanted to tell
you in strange economy like this I value
loyalty and I value a customer that
appreciates what we do for them just
wanted to say thank you and enjoy a cup
of coffee on us with a five dollar
Starbucks card so imagine you're a
customer of ours
covet hits you're already afraid you're
worried no one's calling you
no one wants to talk to you because
they're afraid they're going to cancel
something
and meanwhile I get a
five dollar Starbucks card from you like
what hey babe take this five dollar you
go have a cup of coffee but look look
who just some
that's unbelievable babe because send me
a card no way yeah babe I was about to
cancel the policy yeah babe we could do
it babe I don't know nobody else did
that let's keep the policy if you're in
real estate this applies to everything
if you're in real estate specifically or
loans everybody that's ever bought from
you everybody that's been your customer
send them a letter what a gift and say I
just want to say thank you I value your
relationship a lot hope all is well and
don't ask for nothing
just give it to him and see what happens
with the reaction because they'll
remember that three months six months 12
months 24 months from now okay so these
next three are not going to be
comfortable so race for impact and set
your ego aside for a second and just
just talk to me here Point number four
you ready if you're somebody that
doesn't have a lot of cash and you
didn't save a lot of money maybe you're
making 200 a year 300 a year but you
were really spending money and you
thought the market was going to stay
like that forever and you're in a bad
situation
don't let your ego get too big for you
to not get a part-time job or Uber at
night to make some money to pay your
bills we've all done this I did this
just so you know when I first left
Bally's and I started working at Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter and then I went and
became an independent financial advisor
serious 766 3126 life and health and the
market tanks is like the worst time to
leave your job and that's what happened
to me I left at a time like that
behind closed doors guess what I'm doing
I'm the morning manager at Valley Total
Fitness opening clubs at four o'clock
I'm selling shirts on the corner of
Reseda and Nordhoff right next to CSUN I
would buy shirts at two dollars a pop
and sell it for 15 bucks a pop that's
what I would do to pay my bills during
bad times because I was very comfortable
and by the way I would go to the clubs
on Saturdays and CSUN was like the main
University that most of my friends went
to and guess what guys would say hey
Patrick you look really good I said what
I mean I look really good I got a
freaking shirt on he says yeah I saw you
on the corner of Reseda on nordoff
without a shirt on selling shirts I said
well I was in shape I was like freaking
chiseled I'm like dude whatever it takes
to sell some shirts I'm gonna make some
money right now there was no Uber back
then there was no Amazon drop ship there
was none of that stuff I'm selling
shirts
fast forward 20 years later I'm doing
very good financially but I was not
afraid of me being on the corner of a
street selling shirts to make money to
pay my bills set your ego aside because
the current times are real and it
affects your industry set that ego aside
if you got to do Uber if you got to get
a part-time job if you got to get a
license in another industry to make some
money during this time because you're
not going away from Real Estate go do it
Point number five this is also a tough
one you ready what's beneath you what is
beneath you what do you mean what's
beneath me what's beneath me no not like
that like what's beneath you what's
beneath you like do you realize I'm the
real estate guy that's on brochures and
everybody in my city knows who I am I go
to the Chamber of Commerce they know me
by this name I have this nickname I have
this brand I got you what's beneath you
at a meeting upstairs two days ago and
I'm talking to my sales guys the
consultants and I asked everybody I said
what do you think is beneath me
everybody's thinking quadrax show what I
tell Pat I said if I walk into the
building and I see trash on the floor
I'm the CEO of the company is it beneath
me to pick it up the room was 50 50. so
why shouldn't I pick it up to my
building is it beneath me to keep the
building clean is it beneath me to go
around and talk to people and say hello
is it beneath me to talk to a person
that's doing camera and talk to them
like we're regular people or am I
supposed to be superior on everybody so
what's beneath you Mr realtor Mrs
realtor is it beneath you to do one
thing that Realtors don't want to sell
let's talk about it you know what that
is if you're used to selling an 800 000
house and you make six percent whatever
you make fifty percent on that three
percent twenty four thousand dollars or
you make three percent you make fifty
percent on that twelve thousand dollars
they're like average thing I sell I make
ten thousand dollars commission twenty
thousand dollars commission thirty
thousand on whatever your number maybe
five thousand dollars if you're in
Toledo thirty thousand dollars if you
know York City you know what no one
wants to do today that a lot of people
are doing a lot of people are renting a
lot of them and you can do 12-month
leases 24 month leases and you know how
this works in the real estate industry
if you do a 12 month lease or 24 month
lease you get paid typically two
different ways either the first month's
lease as paid to you by the rental renty
the one that's owning the property or
you get 10 commission so let's do the
math if it's five thousand dollars a
month times 24 months that's 120 000 10
still 12 000 or if it's five thousand
dollars a month they just give you the
first rent that's five thousand dollars
don't be the person that's just chasing
the eight hundred thousand dollar house
the two million dollar house the three
million dollar house go out there and be
willing to lease why because when you do
so many leases and rents you build a
pipeline that when the economy comes
back up two years from now all these
people that you did leases Foreign rents
for guess what you're going to come back
and help 20 percent of them thirty
percent and buy a house next thing you
know three years from like make 500 000
make 600 000 because you're thinking
that way on what's going to happen so
ask the question from yourself what is
beneath you do not be too cool
to go sell what you're not supposed to
sell because the cool people don't do
that go do a lease if you have to
especially during times like this point
number six look at your expenses go
print out all your statements of your
credit cards and go through it one by
one by one what's this 24.99 every month
I pay oh cancel Spotify cancel Pandora
what is this one here why do we have all
these five different platforms maybe
we're canceling which one do we like
let's just keep Netflix let's just keep
Hulu great we're canceling the rest of
them awesome what is this 22.99 a month
what's this 200 we can't eat out anymore
we're eating at three times a week we're
gonna do once a week okay so we're
eating that three times and we're not
gonna do We're not gonna eat out at all
or this expense here why am I paying for
this thing I'm gonna get rid of this car
I'm going to go get a 800 a month lease
instead of a 2200 a month lease look at
your expenses it's basic you know this
I'm not telling you anything you don't
know about but grab your statements from
all your credit cards of your check
cards and one by one by one by one by
one cancel whatever you're no longer
using and have a conversation with your
spouse or your buy yourself conversation
with yourself saying moving forward I'm
not buying this I'm not buying that I'm
not doing this I'm going on a diet with
my expenses because I'm going to tighten
it up it may be 3 6 12 24 months but if
you got to do that you got to do that
point number seven it's very simple
serve serve serve what do you mean
anywhere you can go serve your community
in the movie Gladiator when Maximus is
asking the owner saying hey you you used
to be a gladiator you were a slave now
you're free what happened to you he says
you win the crowd you win your freedom
the way you win your city be the mayor
of your city you go win some votes go
have big voter turnouts for you go do
whatever you can in your community to
serve let them see your face everywhere
serving kids coaching relationships
whatever you can let people fall in love
with you as a person because you serve
you serve and you serve and people
remember that I remember that when I see
how a coach treats my son I go out of my
way to help that person because that guy
served me and my family I got your back
when it comes down to you needing
something from me specifically if you're
in real estate and you want me to buy
something from you if I'm selling you
will have a little bit more of an edge
than the other guy that disappeared for
two years now it shows back up looking
all proper saying hey I'm back how's
everything I'll miss you everything good
what happened last two years when it was
shitty you never called me this guy was
right there helping me out you were not
kind of like this guy more than I like
you I'm gonna do business with him
that's how business works all the time
just so you know that so serve serve
serve Point number eight that's a hard
one to do but an easy one for those who
got big plans think long term any
business you do short-term things are
going to go wrong marriage short term
you're gonna have problems kids
short-term you're gonna have problems
Health short-term you're gonna have
problems finances short term there's
going to be problems anything you do in
your life there's going to be problems
you're gonna have that's going to be
short-term but if you're thinking long
term and you make your moves based on
thinking long-term Poise it's all going
to work itself out you make better
decisions than panicking because all
you're thinking about is short term so
you have to say he would sit down and I
would say short term do I really want to
sell these shirts on the corner here no
man I hate doing this stuff long term
it's not going to work itself out it's
going to be a story I'm going to tell
one that people are going to laugh about
it they're not going to believe it short
term do I really want to go out there
and wake up at 3 30 to go up and open up
the club at Bally's at 4am to make 7.25
an hour yeah I don't want to do that
long term I'm going to tell this story
to my kids when one day they don't want
to do it short term it's going to suck
long term everything's going to work
itself out having said that I got two
videos I want you to watch to help you
out during a time like this but before I
do that look everything to me is
affirmations and I'm a guy that
constantly says future looks right when
nothing's going my way so we created the
future looks bright hats were on the
side it says future looks bright here it
says future looks bright it's a limited
edition valuetainment hats that we
created with these logos you can get it
in black with white you can get it in
all black white and black or red and
black we had a guy to Michigan that
ordered one for himself then he ordered
three then he ordered 58 for everybody
at his office because everyone said I
want a future looks bright hat we're
selling these like hotcakes if you
haven't yet bought one click here to
order your own future looks bright hat
or all four of them and by the way some
limited editions one that are coming out
as well here soon but go get your future
looks bright hat the other video I want
you to watch at a time like this is a
video I did a few years ago titled
customer service versus customer
experience if you've never seen that
click here to watch that and I may even
plug another one here titled The Art of
Getting referrals if you want to get
better at getting referrals click on
this link over here as well take care
everybody bye
[Applause]
[Music]